what is the least common multiple of 36
and 12
so and they say another way to say this
is lcm in parentheses 36 and 12 and this
is literally saying what's the least
common multiple of 36 and 12. well this
one might pop out at you because 36
itself is a multiple of 12. and 36 is
also a multiple of 36. it's 1 times 36.
so the smallest number that is both a
multiple of 36 and 12 because 36 is a
multiple of 12 is actually 36.
there we go let's do a couple more of
these that one was too easy
what is the least common multiple of 18
and 12 and they just state this with a
different notation what's the least
common multiple or the least common
multiple of 18 and 12 is equal to
question mark so let's think about this
a little bit
so there's a couple of ways you can
think about so let's just write down our
numbers that we care about we care about
and
we care about 12. so there's two ways
that we can approach this one is the
prime factorization approach we can take
the prime factorization of both of these
numbers and then construct the smallest
number whose prime factorization has all
of the ingredients of both of these
numbers and that will be the least
common multiple so let's do that
18 is 2 times 9 which is the same thing
as
2 times 3 times 3 or 18 is 2 times 9 9
is 3 times 3. so we could write 18 is
equal to 2
times 3
times 3 that's its prime factorization
12 is 2 times 6 6 is 2 times 3
so 12 is equal to 2 times 2
times 3.
now the least common multiple of 18 and
12 let me write this down so the least
common multiple of 18 and 12
and
is going to have to have
enough prime factors to cover both of
these numbers and no more because we
want the least common multiple or the
smallest common
multiple so let's think about it well it
needs to have at least one two a three
and a three in order to be divisible by
18.
so let's write that down so we have to
have a two times three
times three this makes it divisible by
18. if you multiply this out you
actually get 18. and now let's look at
the 12. so this part right over here let
me make it clear this part right over
here is the part that makes up 18 makes
it divisible by 18.
and then let's see 12
we need two twos and a three well we
already have we already have one three
so our three is taken care of we have
one two so this two is taken care of but
we don't have two twos so we need
another two here so notice now this
number right over here has a 2 times 2
times 3 in it or it has a 12 in it and
it has a 2 times 3 times 3 or an 18 in
it so this right over here is the least
common multiple of 18 and 12. if we
multiply it out
so two times two is four
four times three is twelve twelve times
three is equal to
is equal to thirty six and we are done
now the other way you could have done it
is what i would say just the brute force
method of just looking at the multiples
of these numbers you would say well
let's see the multiples of 18 are 18
36 and i could keep going higher and
higher
and i could keep going and the multiples
of 12 are 12
36 and immediately i say i don't have to
go any i don't have to go any further i
already found a multiple of both and
this is the smallest multiple of both
it is 36. you might say hey why would i
ever do this one right over here as
opposed to this one
a couple of reasons this one you're kind
of it's fun because you're actually
decomposing the number and then building
it back up and also this is a better way
especially if you're doing it with
really really large and hairy numbers
really really really hard large and
hairy numbers where you keep trying to
find all the multiples you might have to
go pretty far to actually figure out
what their least common multiple is here
you'll be able to do it a little bit
more systematically and you'll know what
you're doing